sure it was heroic sacrificing myself
with a team like that but does that make
me a hero
maybe who can really say yeah for sure
man
so where is this legendary maxbot
what's left of him he's right over there
nice catch me he's he's a little bit
more now
do you like that yeah I get it oh come
on Gekko hilarious
all right
[Music]
let the games begin
it KJ raise what happened to your Robo
cleaner that's not important
now yeah yeah I'm on my way down
even wait for me
this should be shouldn't be fun
greetings agents I am Max spot your host
welcome to the danger Dome
use your weapons and set your sights
agents
[Music]
this is gonna hurt agents but remember I
am the effect not a Cause
[Music]
you had your fun now it's my turn
and I'm gonna watch you fight
I'm gonna watch you die
[Music]
foreign
someone go again
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]